poursuit sur ce sujet avec corinne
gendron et les professeurs au
département de stratégie responsabilité
sociale et environnementale à l'uqam
bonsoir monsieur madame gendron on
entendait monsieur legault dire on est
prêt à payer une partie mais
l'entreprise doit payer aussi qui doit
payer en fait dans ce dossier de la
fonderie je pense que ça va de soi
l'entreprise doit payer maintenant il
faut voir comment ça se fait elle avait
quand même le droit d'émettre ces
polluants là là il ya une norme qui est
en train d'être révisée alors il faut
qu'elle s'adapte qu'elle s'ajuste donc
il ya des circonstances particulières
néanmoins on verrait mal le gouvernement
assumer tous les coûts parce que tout à
coup l'entreprise doit respecter la
norme québécoise alors qu'elle
bénéficier d'une exemption de norme
pendant si longtemps et ce qui est un
peu particulier on le disait d'entrée de
jeu l'entreprise glencore qui est
derrière la fonderie ou 1 a réalisé des
profits importants 5 milliards de
dollars américains l'an dernier est ce
que ce serait bien vu la part du
gouvernement d'aider une entreprise déjà
très rentable possiblement avec la
fonderie horne également don de donner
de l'argent pour appuyer des profits
d'une multinationale c'est sûr que c'est
il ya un malaise on se dit comment est
ce que l'argent public vient si on veut
augmenter les profits de l'entreprise
qui est déjà très profitable maintenant
il faut voir comme je le mentionnais le
contexte c'est que là on est une norme
qui change un petit peu du jour au
lendemain ce n'est pas nécessairement à
l'entreprise d'assumer entièrement un
changement aussi brusque bien que ce que
je me dis c'est que l'entreprise devait
bien se douter que les conditions
spéciales dont elle bénéficiait pendant
si longtemps elle est éventuellement
évoluer et on aurait espérer peut-être
qu'elle se mette à de meilleures normes
même si elles profitaient de ce régime
spécial avant qu'il ya une sonnette
d'alarmé qui qui sonne mais vous savez
comment ça se passe pour les entreprises
privées c'est pour moi qui vais vous
l'apprendre madame gendron on prend des
décisions d'investissement lorsqu'on
sait que ce sera rentable
dans ce cas ci la fonderie horne et
l'entreprise glencore laissant entendre
qu' ils vont mettre de l'argent sur la
table est ce que le montant va dépendre
de la rentabilité
qu'on pourra obtenir avec ses
investissements là c'est une excellente
question en fait j'espère que
l'entreprise ne va pas simplement faire
un bilan comptable il va se rendre
compte qu'il ya d'autres choses qui joue
notamment quand on voit des normes se
resserrer il ya une image publique qui
vient avec ça si l'entreprise compte
trop sur les aides gouvernementales
comme si elle était incapable elle même
de s'occuper de la santé des gens je
pense que les gens se rappellent
sûrement bien vu et ça pourrait
lui être
dû être dommageable à plus long terme
donc je pense que c'est pas seulement
une question de rentabilité
comptable il faut voir aussi l'effet que
ça sur l'image de l'entreprise et sa
capacité par la suite à avoir un
dialogue avec les parties prenantes
locales et avec le gouvernement parce
que si une entreprise est mal vue mal
perçu elle va avoir plus de difficultés
à engager un dialogue éventuellement
faire des partenariats qui faciliteront
sa modernisation est ce que ce serait
plus simple ou même souhaitable de
fermer l'usiné simplement écouté je
connais pas assez bien là où
l'entreprise en est est ce que pour elle
c'est absolument impossible de réduire
de façon drastique ses émissions là je
suis pas dans le détail moi je pense que
si c'est possible je vois pas pourquoi
est-ce qu'on fermerait l'usiné
maintenant je pense que c'est l'heure
est venue de se dire pourquoi est ce que
cette entreprise-là bénéficier de normes
exceptionnelle alors que pour le reste
du québec y avait une autre norme qu'on
considérait être garante de la santé de
la population et si on met une la
fonderie horne de côté en fait ce
dossier là nous démontre
quoi en fait est ce que c'est la
réglementation qui manquent de mordant
où on ne fait pas suffisamment
d'inspection pourquoi on a encore
aujourd'hui au québec des entreprises
qui ont acquis on perd mais jusqu'à un
certain point d'émettre dépolluantes de
cette sortie je pense que c'est
peut-être des ententes d'un autre âge
qui comme on l'a dit a maintenant il ya
une renégociation du permis
d'exploitation donc qui viennent à
échéance elle en voit les choses
autrement
les entreprises beaucoup d'entreprises
l'ont bien compris et
modernise elles font les affaires
autrement il y en a d'autres qui
attendent qu'on les pousse un peu et on
aimerait bien qu'elle soit proactive en
fait et je pense que ce qui arrive en ce
moment à glencore à mon avis les
dirigeants savaient très bien que ça
allait arriver c'est dommage que on doit
en parler publiquement sans que
l'entreprise est devant c'est le
problème auquel on fait face aujourd'hui
il ya d'autres joueurs qui sont
polluants quand même au québec bon celui
qui nous vient en tête est d'ailleurs
qui s'est fait un peu taper sur les
doigts par québec aujourd'hui c'est la
cimenterie à port daniel en gaspésie est
ce que vous avez l'impression que ce
dossier-là peut éveiller l'attention de
dirigeants d'autres entreprises et leur
faire prendre conscience des
améliorations je pense effectivement que
ce genre de dossier faire réaliser aux
dirigeants que les risques
environnementaux
peuvent se traduire par des coûts et par
une baisse de rentabilité parce qu'il ya
un risque accru donc l'intégration de ce
qu'on appelle les critères esg
environnement société gouvernance dans
la manière de gérer les entreprises dans
la manière aussi de les évaluer sur les
marchés boursiers est en train de
prendre de l'ampleur et je pense que des
cas comme celui d'aujourd'hui montrent
qu' il ya dix ont une relation très très
serré entre un comportement responsable
le respect de normes pas seulement de
normes d'exception mais de normes
auxquelles on s'attendrait et la
rentabilité à long terme de l'entreprise
un homme gendron c'était limpide et très
intéressant merci d'avoir été là merci
bonsoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
[Musique]